mecheri ça y est on est de retour alors
on est de retour en plateau mais je vais
vous montrer j'ai pas mal de choses à
vous montrer les chiffres déjà on
m'avait énormément manqué et on a ouvert
ce qu'on appelle la canal factory
lakanal factory c'est là que se trouvent
tous les studios
c'est là qu'on tourne toutes les
émissions je voudrais vous montrer en
exclusivité parce qu'on est en train de
construire le décor d'une émission qui
va arriver la semaine prochaine c'est le
décor vous l'avez reconnu d'à prendre ou
à laisser qu'on est en train de monter
regardez donc voilà ça va être là qu'il
va y avoir tous les candidats les 24
candidats seront là je vous montrais le
plateau sur lequel on est c'est un
plateau sur lequel on n'a jamais été il
y avait rien sachez le il n'y avait rien
donc on a construit ce qu'on appelle un
espèce de jardy parc regarder une
ceux-là sont bas les flics alors ses
ballades osait on devait reprendre la
danse mais la danse ce sera plus jamais
comme avant
après ce confinement donc on va tous de
voir danser mine de rien avec un plexi
entre nous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci merci c'est bon c'est le
catastrophe
merci ouais c'est pas mal bravo c'est
bien parce qu'on va faire 12 heures ou
20 ci dessus alors ça c'est pas fini
parce qu'en fait c'est une inondation
donc on attend une moquette qui m'arrive
mais d'une minute à l'autre les gars et
à rungis est encore très bien c'est pas
du tout joue dur et j'ai trouvé
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
souplesse aux pattes palmées canyon
barca je vois des mecs qui ramène une
moquette du bureau qu'elle aimait son
voisin alors attendez on va montrer les
moquettes après parce que alors menacer
le vert le bleu le blanc vous décidez
vert bleu blanc vous bottez d'accord
regardez je peux faire là je peux faire
un câlin voilà je peux faire guardian
mon maxi bien génial à faire un câlin
mon chéri j'ai l'impression qu'on peut
pas faire les missions publiques
il y aura tous les jours une personne du
public
aujourd'hui c'est cette personne bonsoir
vous tirez comment tu t'habitues kevin
kevin alors kévin eux il ya une heure tu
ne savais pas encore talent est là ou
pas du tout voilà tu savais pas du tout
tu feras la personne du public ce soir
tout le public repart avec un iphone
[Applaudissements]
vous allez devoir danser sur un petit
carré comme ça on va faire le test
revenait valérie bénaïm monde est en
boîte de nuit
regardez voilà vous allez faire le test
aperçu voilà vous ambiancer mais vous ne
pouvais pas bouger
d'accord
[Musique]
les gars
au kenya sur sa cousine mater
[Musique]
quand tu débarques fait normal
mon fils
regardez
[Musique]
adhérez ben may
la raymond un petit ont fait tomber un
cassoulet films en paix les autres
questions des gens en ont d autres non
pas parce que vous avez perdu ça y est
c'est mon devoir c'est chacun son tour
alors direct comme ça quand vous serez
producteur d'émissions pour l'instant il
va délivrer d'arrivée
[Musique]
[Rires]
j'avais déjà fait un rêve érotique est
quelqu'un de connu oui qui ça avec julie
robert roberts et robert le col routier
avec villa robert c'est exceptionnel
bravo parce que c'est l'anniversaire de
nikos
on va jouer tout de suite à vis hélium
c'est parti d'une gueule et le retour de
benjamin castaldi johnny c'est parti
blue card l étalage parts à l'époque les
bas je suis moi sorti un lot de la cage
excuse moi ta gueule valérie bédard oui
c'est parti on n'est pas pas manquez pas
ça parce que paraît tuco habré au tchad
où y'a pas moi et dja dja ouais c'est
pas ce qu'attend djadja valérie oui pour
moi c'est toi qui gagnes numéro ça c'est
kenza kenza qu'est notre membre du
public du jour commencèrent à quenza top
qu'elsa qaîda est ce que tu peux nous
faire une petite démonstration de danse
et je danse mais je crois et je danse un
peu mal et mes toiles à hawaï
talbi et frais cattaneo kassali castaldi
à l'excellent orange eu à les y attend
attendez j'ai coupé plutôt le noir
cépage formule n'a pas pourquoi
oui c'est ça va pas du tout il va là il
va aller sur gvt
ce soir je m'appelle nino dans un
instant pour lui souhaiter encore bon
anniversaire et je sais que ses deux
chroniqueurs préférés
c'est jean-michel et benjamins mais jean
michel et benjamins
j'aimerais vous alliez au supermarché
pour acheter
je vous le dis le les ingrédients pour
faire le cadeau d'anniversaire le gâteau
d'anniversaire préféré de mon fils tu as
je mixe casta je me skavsta et j'emmène
est en tout cas le premier en rentrant
caf au printemps c'est jean miquel
première entre carrefour
tu vas jamin castaldi et jean michel
lemaire qui sont actuellement dans les
rayons du supermarché pour trouver tous
les ingrédients la farine les oeufs le
no le beurre le sel ne reprenez pas de
risque énoncés belgique et le premier
halo attentats manche et les mets toi là
parce que je vois je vois tous les
attentats temps via mon fils au
téléphone mon chéri attentes en 2008 aux
séries je vérifie chez bungie a tous les
ingrédients alors attends voilà c'est
bon le sucre c'est bon les mecs
benji montclos celle mon chef bon c'est
vrai mon chéri mon chéri à temps allo
nino
oui mon livre tu m'entends mon chéri
chéri je te passe benjamin puisque il va
te féliciter non c'est bien à barzeh les
lots alors voilà birthday c'est quoi il
avait conçu le jour où il avait la
chasse il le rappeler comment chasse à
patio dans la nature allez dans la sueur
vous allez dans les fleurs là bas ça va
vous avez dans la balle va peser dans
les fleurs de bach à l'appareil photo
reste à aller un peu dans les fleurs est
pas le décor alors oui à orly on s'en
fout en fait important de l'histoire
c'est que ils ont fait l'amour
et moi je me suis rendu compte d'un truc
c'est que les gens classe mais les gens
pensent que pendant le confinement il ya
eu çà chement d'activité sexuelle faut
savoir que qu'est la moitié des français
en couple s'ils n'ont pas fait l'amour
pendant le conflit
on dirait qu'elle va donner les points
de l'euroligue j'adore rapide a appelé à
bercy la date tu es très en beauté afida
c'était la dernière minute
je pense que c'était plus en beauté
quand je serai son plateau mais pour
l'instant c'est juste un clin d'oeil
avec grand plaisir et avec grand plaisir
des télés son plateau très bien à bien
lé grand plaisir des conectus dès qu'on
sera déconfite et dès qu'on pourra
voyager
j'espère que tu verras nous voir afida
oui la semaine prochaine ah oui mais
c'est possible
happy days on peut si on peut on pourra
voyager la semaine prochaine mme et à
miami ou pas moi je suis un ami mais je
peux voyager parce que j'ai un passeport
américain
oui mais on note en france là le
continent d'accord fidh avec plaisir à
bad vient nous voir la semaine prochaine
ce serait génial